[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro en et en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue faut-il en finir au
plus vite avec le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est la question qu'on pose sur twitter
ce soir et on va en débattre avec
vincent treulet devillers bonsoir autant
vincent directeur adjoint la d'action du
figaro et en signale au passage les
loges du politique
le livre que vous avez dirigé aux
éditions tallandier ce normal quand on
est un éditorialiste politique avec vous
avec nous une femme politique également
lucide mais avec un grand p qui co
fondatrice de la fabrique écologique et
membres de la revue de l'excellente et
passionnante revue esprit membres de la
rédaction de la revue esprit avec en une
dans la dernière livraison
l'idée libérale en question est bien sûr
ça fait débat ça fait question et c'est
très intéressant on reviendra ensemble
sur l'actualité de ce matin à la
rencontre assez tendues entre le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti et les syndicats de policiers
dans le cadre du bureau de la sécurité
questions qu'on pose sur twitter eric
dupond moretti et les policiers
peuvent-ils se réconcilier
15 milliards d'euros c'est la rallonge
avancée par bercy pour la relance de
l'économie une rallonge supplémentaire
arrive à une quarantaine de milliards
d'euros au total
avec cette fois ci l'idée d'en finir
progressivement avec le quoi qu'il en
coûte c'est en tout cas ce qu'annonce
sur toutes les antennes le ministre de
l'économie et il l'a lancé
encore ce matin projet de loi de
finances de transition qui doit nous
faire passer de la période de crise
économique et de protection totale à un
retour à la vie économique normale et
dans la vie économique normale les
entreprises fonctionnent sans le soutien
de l'état
l'économie française n'a pas vocation à
être placés en permanence sous perfusion
et un moment donné il faut sortir du
quoi qu'il en coûte quand nous sommes
arrivés à ce moment nous le faisons nous
sommes arrivés à ce moment de la sortie
du quoi qu'il en coûte
mais nous le faisons
progressivement et de leur côté les
entreprises sont assez confiante
c'est en tout cas le discours officiel
depuis quelques jours en tout cas le
discours tenu par l'un des plus éminents
représentants d'entre elles le président
du medef geoffroy roux de bézieux
mais je ne suis pas trop inquiet pour
deux raisons la première c'est que il va
y avoir pas une forte demande des
consommateurs dans pratiquement tous les
secteurs
ça va être vrai dans la restauration ça
va être vrai dans les commerces deuxième
chose il n'y aura pas de murs des
faillites durera bien sûr des gens qui
vont déposer le bilan mais il y aura pas
un mois de septembre et d'octobre
des dizaines de milliers de filles
vincent on se demande si roux de bézieux
dit vrai si tous les indicateurs sont
aussi vert que ceux annoncés par bruno
le maire il faut dans ce cas là pas
aller plus vite
je pense quand même que la boe dans le
maire de prudence et qu' il a raison
c'est à dire que cette moment du dégel
où c'est comme ça qu'il l'appelait au
mois de janvier
en parlant de la la fin de l'aide pour
revenir à une économie qui serait moins
assistés et
et créer chez chez lui et chez beaucoup
demande du gouvernement une inquiétude à
la fois économique sociale et politique
donc tout le jeu et de faire les choses
avec le plus de doigté possible avec
deux écueils qu'il faut éviter la
précipitation qui pourrait entraîner des
conséquences rapides et et avec des
effets sociaux très très évident et puis
le maintien des aides par un certain
nombre de dérogations par aussi
peut-être une volonté politique d'aller
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle pour
artificiellement porter une économique
que l'état protège de façon
spectaculaire depuis maintenant un an et
demi donc c'est un je ne pense pas que
qu'il faille aller plus vite mon avis le
choix de bruno le maire et et le bon la
seule question en fait elle est
psychologique c'est à dire que on a
appris à vivre avec ces aides
on a appris à travailler autrement
parfois ne pas travailler tout en étant
payés et tout ça n'est pas sans
conséquence et pour l'activité est pour
même le rapport on y reviendra peut-être
après après plus il est donné à son tour
son avis mais le rapport au travail à
mon avis a profondément changé depuis un
an et demi et peut avoir des
conséquences qui peuvent être
préoccupantes
avant de discuter de débattre sur
justement le rapport au travail du cible
est-ce que vous partager l'optimisme de
geoffroy roux de bézieux
non si c'est pas une question piège non
fob sans s'en vouloir
la kz2 la question c'est c est ce que
geoffroy roux de bézieux parle pour les
pme est-ce qu'ils parlent pour les
salariés précaires ou est-ce qu'il parle
pour les grands groupes c'est à dire que
je pense que le discours très globale
aujourd'hui pour dire les choses vont
aller bien la croissance sera au rendez
vous les consommateurs consommeront la
même manière ça dépend du niveau de
revenu ça dépend des anticipations des
consommateurs et ça dépend des secteurs
dans lesquels on se trouve et des
territoires
donc moi j'aurais tendance à dire que
avoir un discours positif global c'est
plutôt une bonne chose parce que je
pense qu'on a besoin
de retrouver une espèce d'optimisme en
revanche prédire déjà ce qui va se
passer étant donné la complexité de la
question économique et de la question
sociale ça me semble constituer un
exemple les transports on voit bien que
la question du secteur automobile de ce
qui se passe dans l'aviation à la fois
en termes industriels et long terme
simplement de voyage ces deux sujets sur
lesquels le gouvernement a mis en place
des plans des particuliers parce qu'ils
pensent qu'il ya une crise une crise de
ce secteur qui va aller au delà de la
pandémie
un autre exemple ça peut être certains
territoires où justement ces industries
sont plus implantés comment est-ce qu'on
va travailler sur à la fois la relance
et la transformation je rappelle qu'il
s'agit d'une relance verte dire qu'on a
assumé le fait de dire qu'il s'agit pas
seulement de promouvoir la croissance et
le rebond de la consommation aussi
transformer le modèle économique et
social
peut-être un troisième troisième
remarque sans vouloir être trop
compliqué c'est que tout dépend au fond
d'eux est ce que vous êtes un salarié
protégé ou pas est-ce que vous avez la
sécurité de l'emploi est ce que vous
avez un bon niveau de salaire ou est ce
que vous êtes en train de chercher un
emploi reparlons des jeunes des
étudiants de ceux qui au fond se
retrouver en plein précarité pendant la
pandémie
aujourd'hui être un jeune demandeur
d'emploi je pense que c'est compliqué
surtout si on n'est pas très qualifiés
donc tout ça me semble devoir être
nuancée et puis en revanche le quoi
qu'il en coûte ça a coûté plus de 160
milliards d'euros à l'état ce quoi qu'il
en coûte c'est vrai qu'il ya un moment
où on ne peut pas penser que l'état se
substitue à une économie qui n'est pas
une économie administrée
là je rejoins ce que dit bruno le maire
on n'est pas une économie administrée
160 milliards c'est quasiment la moitié
d'un budget annuel quoi exactement donc
pour chardons bleus qui ne regarde en ce
moment quand ça lui nous dit il faut
continuer à aider un peu certaines
entreprises
ce sera intéressant vous me disiez à
qu'elles ont de l'entreprise vous pensez
à quel type d'entreprise vous pensez est
ce que comme lucille vous pensez
notamment au secteur du transport
secteur du tourisme
peut être est également
vous ne de l'événementiel qui est quand
même dévasté et qui pour le moment ne
peut pas retrouver même pas un pouvoir
trouver un pourcentage vraiment infime
de ski de ce qu'ils pouvaient faire et
de ce qu'il réalise est autrefois c'est
que ça fait quand même partie des
secteurs qui devront pouvoir être aidées
encore pendant un moment
vous disiez tout à l'heure justement le
rapport au travail a profondément changé
et c'est un c'est un enjeu de cette
sortie du quoi qu'il en coûte de se dé
confinement on rappelle que c'est à
partir du 9 juin que le les
réglementations vont évoluer par rapport
au télétravail qui jusqu'à présent est
la règle et va la règle va évoluer avec
moins de présence obligatoire en
télétravail à ce moment là quand vous
dites que justement c'est un enjeu par
rapport à ça c'est à dire que vous êtes
pessimiste par rapport aux ansériens je
sais pas comment ça va tourner tout son
but il a montré sa prudence tout à
l'heure et je la rejoins c'est à dire
que on a on a cru sortir de cette
histoire puis on est revenu plusieurs
fois donc il est en a dit ensuite que ça
se finirait en émeute à la sortie puis
maintenant on dit que ces deux ça va se
passer extraordinairement bien
bon je pense que tout ça est quand même
très très fragile mais cette situation a
créé des précédents plusieurs précédents
on en a souvent parlé ici il ya le
précédent des libertés publiques avec
des décisions administratives qui
peuvent en 24 heures
transformer la vie des gens sur un
impératif sanitaire mais qui pourrait
demain être écologique ou sécuritaires
et qui fait que l'administration a
maintenant un pouvoir sur une liberté de
détails qu'il n'a qu'elle n'avait pas
autrefois mais j'écarte ça puisque ce
n'est pas le sujet mais il ya aussi un
précédent sur les possibilités qu'ont
offert de quoi qu'il en coûte
quelles sont ces possibilités ça a quand
même été l'expérience éprouvée d'une vie
salariés sans travailler pour certains
puisqu'il ne pouvait pas travailler
puisque laurent serre notamment au
chômage partiel voilà ce qu'on appellera
vitalité leurs activités étaient était
et est empêchée et
il me semble que ça n'ait ça ne peut pas
ne pas avoir de conséquence c'est à dire
que ça peut avoir une conséquence
positive qui est la volonté et on l'a vu
avec les restaurateurs quand les choses
ouvre de se jeter sur le métier pour
essayer de l'accomplir de la façon la
plus enthousiaste possible mais ça peut
aussi créer une habitude proche de ce qu
était le projet du revenu universel
c'est à dire d'une vie qui serait une
vie organisée selon l'aide de l'état et
non plus selon le le travail réalisé
donc et il va y avoir une
une remise or en rythmant en commander
rang des retrouvailles avec 1
rythme naturel de l'existence qui a été
absolument déréglé je pense la même
chose avec l'école d'ailleurs on le voit
que l'arrêt de l'école a fait feu sur
les élèves
une possibilité psychologique de deux
courts en pointillés et bien de la même
façon on va voir ça avec les salariés et
on va voir ça quand on va voir
obésité est certainement temps quand on
va voir certaines entreprises fermées on
va avoir une incompréhension de
l'opinion disant pourquoi l'état qui
était capable de déverser des dessins
des dizaines de milliards pendant un an
et demi ne viendrait pas on est des sept
entreprises quand bien même cette
entreprise n'aura plus de pertinence
économique donc je crois que ses
précédents ont transformé profondément
la psychologie collective
est ce que vous partagez la prévention
de la censure sur ce rapport au travail
je pense que vincent a raison de dire
qu'on a besoin de retrouver ses marques
et que c'est pas évident que chaque
individu les retrouve seul et donc la
question de comment est-ce qu'on
retrouve collectivement nos marques et
qu'on se remet effectivement à
travailler mais en ayant le sentiment de
l'utilité je pense que ce qui a changé
pendant la pandémie c'est que la
question du sens
la question de l'articulation entre le
court terme et le moyen terme a changé
et que par exemple la question du rôle
de l'état
moi je nous écoutant je me disais il
faut pas seulement penser la question du
rôle de l'état évidemment par rapport à
lèvres de court terme - dette de court
terme sans doute mais plus d'action
publique et de capacité à investir de
l'état c'est aussi un des enseignements
de la crise c'est à dire que ce qu'on a
découvert ce qui s'est passé autour de
l'hôpital
la question l'éducation par exemple
quand jean michel blanquer annonce une
revalorisation du salaire des
enseignants
je suis pas sûr que ces choses-là se
serait passé s'il y avait pas eu la
pandémie donc on est dans une situation
au fond la question de la dépense
publique elle est aujourd'hui vu très
différemment le sait il ya 18 mois et il
s'agit pas de dépenser à tombeau ouvert
mais dépenser justement et de façon à
assurer l'avenir ça c'est un point
important alors là où c'est simplement
il ya c'est vrai une petite révolution
qui va plaire à lui s'il est qui qui va
déplaire à un certain nombre de
de nos téléspectateurs qui sont de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
c'est que il me semble que le rallye
120-112 de l'autre côté de l'ordinateur
on peut dire que c'est des internautes
voilà voilà 2le la question de la
rigueur budgétaire qui est nos coeurs
d'un certain discours de droite
à mon avis sera inaudible pendant
l'élection présidentielle avec l'anah et
demi que nous avons passé et si le
candidat de la droite se fait
l'équivalent de ce qui était françois
fillon sur ce plan simplement de la
rigueur budgétaire et de la dépense
publique il risque fort de se mettre à
dos un certain nombre d'électeurs même
ceux qui autrefois pourrait soutenu
cette famille politique parce que là il
ya eu aussi des bouleversements à la
fois psychologique et peut-être même
structurelles sur ce sujet et alors est
ce que c'est ça ou c'est malsain selon
ben il faut aussi me posez la question à
la wii
encore une fois le cas sinon à
l'éditorialiste et après je pars et je
ne veux pas vous allez dire que je veux
pas trancher mais je crois que les
situations exceptionnelles comme celle
que l'on a vécu ont des conséquences qui
sont ambivalentes
donc on ne peut pas tirer un seul fil en
disant de toute façon ça va être pire
le jour d'après ou ça va être enfin les
jours heureux je ne crois pas mais je
pense que si on a une réflexion de la
rigueur brainard mais si on a une
réflexion sur le périmètre de l'état et
sur les lieux où il faut défendre ce
périmètre et et l'hôpital fait partie du
régalien la question de la sécurité très
importantes aussi l'école aussi si on
décide de renforcer et de financer des
secteurs qui sont aujourd'hui appauvri
c'est une bonne chose et si on supprime
un certain nombre de dépenses qui sont
superfétatoire ou qui s'accumulent sans
qu'elle est grand ce sens voilà donc ces
il n'y a pas de réponse tranchée
je pense que ce que je veux dire c'est
que le discours purement et d'économies
en 10 ans il faut faire tant d'économie
par secteur est un discours qui à mon
avis aujourd'hui et inaudibles parce que
le lieu où l'on a fait ça c'est comme un
hôpital et on s'est aperçu
pendant cette période que c'était une à
lui seul moi je pense qu'il faut pas
toujours accoler le terme de rigueur à
la question de l'économie sans
discernement on peut dépenser de manière
rigoureuse la dépense publique mais il
s'agit de faire des investissements
et je rappelle qu'on est face à des
élections le rassemblement national qui
récupère la colère face à la disparition
des services publics est très fort c'est
le deuxième parti partout voir le
premier on verra ce qui se passe au
deuxième tour des élections régionales
mais enfin on est dans une situation le
rassemblement national et comme déjà
qualifiés pour la présidentielle et donc
par rapport à cette question là il faut
apprendre à gérer la dépense publique
d'abord d'une manière plus coordonnée
entre les différents acteurs publics
avec rigueur mais en faisant les
investissements d'avenir nécessaires
pour assurer l'égalité dans les
territoires sur le transport par exemple
certes il ya une crise du secteur des
transports par rapport à la voiture
individuelle mais est-ce qu'on peut
doter les territoires de transport en
commun ça c'est un vrai sujet comment
est-ce qu'on travaille pour assurer
cette égalité d'accès aux services
publics
c'est un vrai sujet est à mon avis le
budget de l'état et de l'action publique
en général il est il doit être revu dans
cette optique jeu justement
même si le temps film et vous poser une
autre question sur les précédents qui
ont été qui ont été créés alors je note
que vous faites vous mettez de l'hôpital
dans le régalien je vous que je suis un
peu étonné par rapport à ça mais bon ça
c'est un autre débat
j'aurais bien dit ça il ya ya ya deux
ans mais bon là il est évident que c'est
le le sida year on avait déversé une
partie du quoi qu'il en coûte sur
l'hôpital pour que les personnels
soignants 1 30 % dans certains hôpitaux
sont partis entre septembre et novembre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas supporté la
première vague et la façon dont on
ont été traités comme en été traitées
l'hôpital si on avait plutôt que
financer des projets sur moteur à
hydrogène qui sont très bien mais qui
était peut-être moins concret évident
mis cet argent pour les personnels
soignants et pour créer des lits de
réanimation
peut-être qu'on aurait éviter de fermer
l'intégralité du pays comme on l'a fait
donc il me semble que cette crise a
montré
mais encore une fois faux c'est ce que
dit lucide c'est une dépense qui fait de
discernement qui est intelligente mais
qui rigoureuse mais à montrer que
l'hôpital avait besoin d'argent et que
si on l'avait développé on aurait pu
affronter mieux ce qui s'est passé juste
une dernière une dernière question
est-ce que c'est pas aussi le moment de
d'amplifier un virage qui sont la vie
des précédentes créances dans ce domaine
sur la relocalisation la protection de
l'économie est même allé plus loin comme
le disait l'économiste
l'économiste patrick artus la semaine
dernière c'est la fin de l'économie du
moins cher oui c'est hyper intéressant
l'histoire la relocalisation
ca va montrer que vincent par le
question de questions régaliennes moi je
pense que l'aménagement du territoire va
être totalement bouleversée par ce qui
est en train de se passer
je voudrais quand même insisté sur le
fait qu on dit aussi des choses assez
contradictoires entre elles ou entre
lesquels il ya des tensions
par exemple on dit qu'on va relocaliser
l'industrie et par ailleurs on est
beaucoup plus écologique
re nature dans un certain nombre
d'endroits on nous dit faut faire les
villes autrement
il va falloir assumer le fait qu'on peut
pas faire en tout cas tout à la fois sur
le même territoire comment est-ce qu'on
assemble les choses comme on les fait
aussi acceptée par l'opinion publique
moi je vois par exemple monter un
mouvement assez contrôlé aux liens parce
que c'est une industrie qui en fait est
répartie sur le territoire
je me disais si on remet des grands
sites industriels il faut voir comment
on fait on peut peut être utilisé les
friches industrielles qui sont nombreux
en france mais il faut réfléchir du coup
de manière assez film et ce qui est
important je reprends sur l'histoire la
santé c'est de faire travailler ensemble
les acteurs par exemple sur l'hôpital
moi je trouve qu'on aurait dû travailler
davantage on l'a déjà dit ici mais
certes avec les cliniques privées mais
surtout avec les médecins généralistes
comment est ce qu'on fait pour organiser
cette interaction entre acteurs de façon
à relocaliser re nature et
redonnez aussi une espèce de côté
presque charnel à la relation entre
l'état et la société moi c'est un de mes
points essentiels je vous que l'état ne
doit plus être dans une tour d'ivoire
qu'il faut apprendre à connaître qui
sont les fonctionnaires qu'ils aient le
droit aussi de parler davantage avec les
citoyens cueillez pas seulement les
politiques qui puisse au fond faire des
tweets enfin je dis pas qu'il faut
qu'ils font bien face des tweets mais en
tout cas que la relation entre euros
chacun d'entre nous les généraux des
tribunes la question de comment est-ce
qu'on refait ce lien ce dialogue et
comment on organise l'acceptabilité
sociale
on semble être aujourd'hui un point
important le rassemblement national se
nourrit de la méfiance et de
l'abstraction
moi je crois perfusé les entreprises et
les français n'est pas une solution nous
dit cats sur twitter que tous puissent
retrouver leur emploi ça suffit d'en
tester les générations futures
ricoh sur lefigaro.fr l'argent magic est
un puits sans fond nicole fidèles
internautes qu'on salue il faudra bien à
un moment ou un autre rembourser ce
n'est pas la peine de ce mode de se
demander qui va payer et une autre qui
nous disent c'est vrai que sortir de
l'endormissement sera difficile c'est
d'ailleurs aussi on peut répondre très
rapidement et on va parce que c'est à
peu près la même note chacun chacun des
commentaires que vous avez lu il
faudrait quand même posé la question
essayez d'imaginer le scénario s'il n'y
avait pas eu ces aides
et si on avait vu des entreprises mourir
les unes après les autres moi je parlais
l'autre jour avec un commerçant qui m'a
dit c'est la première fois depuis que je
travaille il a 60 ans que l'état vient
mon aide
ça n'est jamais arrivé et donc j'ai
passé un moment très difficile ça va je
si jo que si j'avais 20 ans je serai
décourager devant les 60
donc je suis à la fin de ma carrière
mais je vais pouvoir ré ouvrir et
pouvoir travailler jusqu'à ma retraite
ça compte aussi donc il est évident que
ça a coûté très cher et qu'il va falloir
le rembourser mais quel prix aurions
nous payer si jamais on avait tenu la
rigueur budgétaire plus importante que
le maintien de l'emploi
e quoi qu'il en coûte est il encore
possible c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter et vous répondez
une large majorité merci d'avoir répondu
80 % donc c'est plus qu'une large
majorité
l'autre question qu'on vous pose sur
twitter c'est si eric dupond moretti et
la police peuvent se réconcilier il faut
dire que l'ambiance était assez tendue
ce matin place beauvau entre syndicats
de policiers et le ministre de
l'injustice de la justice excusez moi
c'était pas c'était même pas là dessus
c'est un problème d'articulation
donc il était venu parler devant les
syndicats dans le cadre de ce qui est ce
qu'on appelle le beauvais de la sécurité
le ministre de la justice a défendu en
tout cas son institution de nouveau très
critiquée par les syndicats de policiers
en écoute dans la globalité des peines
qui sont prononcés dans notre pays je
vous ai de les chiffres la justice est
plus dure peut-être pas aussi dur que
vous le souhaiteriez mais il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ça s'appelle
l'indépendance plaidoyer pour
l'indépendance de la justice de la part
d'eric dupond-moretti de son côté le
ministre de l'intérieur a temporisé la
police et la justice fonctionne ensemble
c'est une tautologie de dire est que
pour moi la police et la justice
encore plus les relations entre les deux
ministres ce n'est pas un duel c'est un
duo c'est un binôme et parce que si
c'est un duel
alors forcément il y a un des deux qui
perd ou les deux qui perdent est par
nature parce que nous sommes que de
passage c'est toute institution tout
l'état et de la nation qui perdent alors
attendant de revenir sur justement le
duel où le duo voici à la sortie la
réaction d'un des syndicats de policiers
le syndicat sgp police on reste sur
notre faim pour l'instant mais mais je
ne désespère pas j'ai rappelé l'article
30 ans 232 19 de la loi de belloubet de
mars 2019 qui vient justement précisé
que finalement l'exception c'est
l'emprisonnement est ce qu'à un moment
donné on se dit pas qui on a on s'est un
peu trompé de chemin et ce qui n'est pas
le temps de faire marche arrière
j'ai demandé à ce que les agresseurs de
forces de l'ordre soient sortis de cet
article là
vincent travaux les îles à il a raison
ce syndicaliste de ne pas désespérer ou
le hiatus et il est trop fort je trouve
en réfléchissant à cette querelle qui
est une querelle permanente entre la
place beauvau et vendôme acebo vous qui
créent le plus fort ses grandes oeuvres
les plus forts rebonds qu'il faut faire
attention à pas se laisser emporter par
le théâtre communicationnel que l'on
nous sert je pense que la situation
n'est pas la même que quand on nous
évoque les manifs de policiers devant le
bureau de robert badinter sous françois
mitterrand où l'affrontement manuel
valls christiane taubira il ya des
seuils qui ont été franchies depuis
d'abord il ya des policiers qui sont
morts en nombre durant l'exercice de
leurs fonctions et puis il ya une
violence qui se développe de façon
irrationnelle et aveugle c'est un élu en
côte d'or qui se fait tabasser pas ce
qu'il dit à un quad qu'il faut qu'il
fasse attention sur un chemin de halage
c'est un médecin qui quitte son cabinet
à mantes la ville parce que son cabinet
a été dévastée alors que ça fait des
années qu'ils travaillent là-bas ce sont
des signes qui nous révèle quelque chose
d'une société complètement déréglé et
dans laquelle le cadre habituel de la
bataille entre la célèbre en gros
l'impératif sécuritaire les grands
principes de l'état de droit
apparaissent comme des mots creux c'est
à dire que la sécurité n'est plus
assurée l'état est affaissé et le droit
s'en mêlent dans un code de procédure
pénale qui est de plus en plus important
est de plus en plus compliqué et donc je
crois que le
duo duel que nous sert gérald darmanin
et eric dupond moretti est un peu là
pour occuper la galerie et vous m'avez
compris je pense que la crise est
beaucoup plus profonde en fait c'est à
dire qu'on vit une crise de l'autorité à
tous les étages de la société et dont
les conséquences visibles se font sur le
dernier rempart de l'autorité qui est la
police et les forces de maintien de
l'ordre mais je crois pas que la réponse
pour terminer soit policière ou
simplement judiciaire c'est quasiment
une réponse de civilisation qu'il faut
apporter à un moment que nous vivons
alors justement soit la réponse de
socialisation rien de tel que d'avoir le
commentaire du membre de la rédaction de
la revue
merci vincent moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que gérald darmanin a invoqué les
institutions et l'état chose que je
trouve dans sa bouche intéressante
je ne m'y attendais pas alors prêt de
plusieurs choses d'abord eric
dupond-moretti moi je trouve incarne
avec beaucoup de force
cette position 7 de ministre de la
justice et je alors il a eu maille à
partir d'ailleurs avec les magistrats
parce que c'est un avocat et je trouve
ça intéressant et je trouve intéressant
qu'il est le verbe de haut
pourquoi parce que je rejoins mon
dupond-moretti lorsqu'il dit que les
français ne savent pas comment
fonctionne la justice dans notre pays et
que en revanche il mesure c'est beaucoup
plus évident comment fonctionne la
police on a plus souvent affaire à une
police de proximité on sait qui est
policier on sait qui est gendarme etc
on s'est beaucoup moins comment
fonctionne la justice et du coup la
tentation d'accuser la justice de
dysfonctionner d'être trop faible est
une tentation
d'ailleurs en plus quand elle est
relayée par les syndicats de policiers
qui est une tentation de facilité donc
je trouve que la posture de dupond
moretti est une bonne posture
je trouve ça intéressant aussi que
gérald darmanin est choisi au fond
d'être modéré dans sa posture alors que
c'est quelqu'un qui a plutôt l'habitude
quelque part de faire de la provocation
confère le fait qu'il avait dit qu'il
allait engager un procès contre audrey
pulvar
donc ça ça me semble bien la deuxième
chose qu'il faut dire ça a été dit et
redit c'est que la france n'a pas les
moyens d'une justice correct par rapport
au droit qu'elle développe et c'est vrai
que le gouvernement actuel doté le
budget de la justice a de recruter des
magistrats et que du coup le
rééquilibrage entre une justice qui
fonctionne et une police qui
fonctionnerait mieux étant est en cours
donc ça c'est un deuxième point que je
trouve important le troisième point
c'est évidemment l'ambiance c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on voit lorsqu'on entend les
interventions des représentants
syndicaux de la police
on sent une colère très forte on l'a vu
pendant la manifestation on sent aussi
une tentation parfois de s'affranchir de
sa responsabilité en tant qu agent
public c'est à dire que ya l'idée qu'au
fond on va mettre la pression sur le
pouvoir politique et qu'on va se servir
quelque part de sa force électorale moi
je trouve que c'est condamnable et donc
tout l'enjeu c'est aussi que les
policiers restent dans les institutions
et que la confiance revienne entre la
société et la police c'est à dire que
peut-être que les policiers n'ont plus
confiance dans la société
mais la société se pose des questions
doudou le débat qu'on a eue sur utilisé
ou pas l'expression de violences
policières je rappelle ce qui s'est
passé sur l'interview d'emmanuel macron
sur brut où il a parlé de violence 2
certains policiers je viens la fois ils
ont policière et ça vous arrange ou en
suisse ensuite il est revenu sur des
stations et lens position qu'on voit
bien que tout le vocabulaire est piégé
et où vincent a raison c'est que tout le
débat est hanté par une sorte de
polémique qui ne cesse de s'accroître et
qu'il ne faut pas séparer le fait
d'avoir un droit à la sécurité est un
droit à la justice
ce ne sont pas de droits contradictoires
non mais la difficulté devant laquelle
on est c'est que mon avocat des droits
qu'on oppose au feu alors qu'ils ne sont
pas contraires c'est à dire le droit de
se promener tranquillement et l'état de
droit et le droit d'être attachés à des
libertés publiques d'être défendus et de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une justice
équitable
ça c'est ce qu'on affiche mais le
problème et moi c'est ça qui m'inquiète
et c'est pour ça que là je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur eric dupond
moretti c'est que la vocation des grands
principes à mon avis abymes
quand derrière cette invocation ces
grands principes ont dans l'opinion
publique devienne le paravent ou du
renoncement ou d'une forme de laxisme ou
d'une forme d'impuissance c'est à dire
que assez souvent
le garde des sceaux dit c'est comme ça
parce que c'est ça notre grandeur c'est
ça la république et qu'est ce
qu'entendent les gens ça veut dire la
république c'est qu'il ya des choses que
l'on ne peut pas faire écho au fait il
ya un risque à vivre dans notre pays et
que ce risque il faut le prendre parce
que si on voulait le limiter on empiète
ray sur l'héritage de nos libertés
publiques moi je ne crois pas que ce
soit le cas je pense que c'est
simplement parce qu on a abandonné
l'application simple de la loi
même pas on n'arrête pas de parler là
deux possibilités législatives moi je ne
peux plus dire aucune des lois non
appliquées c'est insensé et que cette
application de la loi dans le cadre du
droit devrait être beaucoup plus ferme
je voyais ce syndicaliste qui rappelait
la prison comme exception aussi pour des
raisons de place manquantes mais je
je pense que moi dans cette histoire
l'éducation compte beaucoup et que
l'éducation n'existe pas sans la
sanction il n'y a pas d'éducation sans
sanction est qu'aujourd'hui la sanction
alors elle est prononcée
c'est lé chiffre qu'avance eric dupond
moretti mais le s quel et exécutés non
entre la peine encourue
la peine prononcée et la peine exécutée
il y aurait des tableaux statistiques à
faire et là on verrait la différence
entre les trois j'ai juste une question
vous lancer de twitter sur ce que vous
disiez vous vous étiez le problème de
confiance entre la société à société la
police bon alors au limbourg répond
maintenant la société n'est pas anti
police mais c'est parce que j'ai voulu
dire non mais enfin bon voilà on lui
donnait la parole et vous lui a demandé
il ya un autre phénomène c'est que il ya
quand même 80 % des français trouvent la
justice trop laxiste 81%
est-ce que la réponse de dupond moretti
sur ce qu'ils disaient sur
l'indépendance de la justice où
effectivement l'écart sur les peines de
prison qui ce qui était donné un parent
syndicats de policiers alors les plus
durs 1 c'était alliance mais qui était
quasiment un écart de 1 à 10 entre la
peine théorique et la peine réellement
prononcées par par les juges qui
s'empare est-ce que c'est pas de nature
justement à rompre cette confiance entre
la population et la justice sachant
comme vous le disiez que on connaît pas
assez bien cette institution et que
l'expérience qu'on a souvent c'est que
quand on met qu'un procès ça prend des
plombes
en tous les cas on passe des plombes on
met des plombes à passer devant un juge
et et ex et ex est toujours lent entre
le moment passé en plus souvent la
décision il ya plusieurs choses sur la
justice et c'est là que moi je trouve qu
eric dupond moretti est un bon avocat de
la justice c'est que comme on vient de
le dire elle a pas suffisamment de
moyens donc comme vous le dites vincent
quand on engage une action judiciaire ou
quand on est dans une traînée dans une
action judiciaire on sait que ça prendra
beaucoup de temps et que le lien entre
la réalité et le jugement sera distendu
lorsque le jugement sera rendu donc ça
c'est un premier point qui crée la
défiance la deuxième chose c'est que ce
manque de moyens c'est un manque de
moyens matériels et humains criant et on
parle beaucoup de l'absence de moyens du
côté de la sécurité et de la police mais
il
beaucoup plus criant encore faut-il
comparer en tout cas puisqu'on parlait
d'investissement que l'état allait dans
la justice dans le régalien ça me semble
est un point essentiel
la troisième chose c'est qu'il ya une
trop grande complexité la justice par
rapport à notre culture générale et aux
justiciables donc on a le sentiment
qu'au fond en fonction des accès qu'on a
peut-être de l'argent qu'on a aussi
assumons le la justice est réservé à
certains et qu'elle n'est pas la même
pour tous donc ce sentiment de méfiance
je crois qu'il est fondée ou 6 sur
l'idée d'une inégalité d'accès et d'une
inégalité de décision et ça je trouve
que c'est essentiel qu'on s'y attelle et
la suspicion porté par les policiers par
rapport à la justice à mon sens c'est
plutôt une suspicion par rapport au fait
qu' ils ont le sentiment aussi de ne pas
être assez écouté d'être parfois
maltraités de faire un travail ingrat
mais ça ne justifie pas le fait de
concentrer leur colère sur la justice je
trouve que ça c'est scandaleux et je
pense que quand on est partie prenante
de l'état et d'une institution on doit
être partie prenante globalement et pas
segmenter les choses moi c'est un point
vraiment fondamental et puis et puis il
ya eu ce dernier point rapide
non mais on a bien vu que dans le fait
d'aller participer à la manifestation
des policiers
il ya eu 10 compris des espèces de
prises de position parfois un peu
polémique ou démagogique de certains et
je trouve que les policiers mérite mieux
que ça je pense que il suffit pas
d'aller jeter trois phrases dans une
manifestation de policiers pour en fait
et du procès des policiers fait de ce
qu'ils vivent
moi je joue et je partage votre point de
vue cette manifestation enfin à mon avis
n'a pas été analysé ac en profondeur
dans ce qu'elle révèle de la crise de
l'état mais elle elle est la conséquence
directe d'une une suite d'agressions il
n'ya sûr que petites moyennes ou
terrible que vivent les policiers et
dans l'indifférence mais on ne peut pas
on peut pas surfé on peut pas être
démagogue par rapport à la douleur est
donc s'il n'y a pas un rétablissement
assez rapide d'un certain nombre de
principes élémentaires d'autorité on va
voir ses sept déséquilibré de différents
représentants de l'état qui vont les uns
contre les autres dire c'est que ça doit
pas se passer comme ça c'est c'la procès
quand même en voilà eric dupond-moretti
la justice peuvent ils se réconcilient
cité la question que vous posez
sur twitter vous répondez non à 76% donc
vous êtes encore plus pessimiste au
début ce que c'était à 75% général
escape sur youtube où nous disent les
français et la police sont d'accord pour
dire qu'il ya trop de laxisme dans la
justice mais 80% c'est les chiffres
dernier sondage sur la question les
violences et la récidive ne sont pas
punis alors juste valeur estimée vous
eric dupond-moretti n'est pas un
ministre de la justice mais il reste un
avocat nous dit nicole mais comme le dit
lucide c'est un très bon avocat en tous
les cas de son institution et ça on a pu
le voir s'en rendre compte ce matin
le problème n'est pas un problème de
personne estime bennett sur youtube
c'est un problème culturel de
construction de manteaux rites et donc
rien ne sera réparé sans une reprise en
main de certains principes et certaines
institutions
babineau il y a un vrai désaccord de
fond entre dupond-moretti les
revendications des syndicats de police
c'est un dialogue de sourds
effectivement c'est ce qui ressort de ce
qu'on a pu voir de cette séquence du
bureau de la sécurité aujourd'hui cédric
sur youtube la justice n'est pas laxiste
elle est juste extrêmement tolérante
les aménagements de peine devrait être
interdit pour les multirécidivistes
estimez vous c'est votre opinion c'est
votre point de vue merci beaucoup de
nous l'avoir donné et merci vincent
merci d'utiliser de nous l'avoir partagé
ce soir et c'était comme d'habitude très
intéressant on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit au tour de guillaume
roquette ferghana ziari et guillaume
bigot a très vite sur figaro life